yes I did forget that part
Child Protective Services will interview each of your children individually
as well one of my children is disabled and nonverbal
they still pull her and like
sit with her and attempt to talk to her
but now they do it at school
they have never had them do it at school before
but this time they came to my house saying
we've already met with the kids
we've already talked to them
we've heard their side
so it's like because you better fucking be honest
because kids are honest
kids don't know how to lie
and especially they catch them in the middle of the day at school
the kid is gonna
you know and you know
say what
what the fuck is going on in their life so
also the the Child Protective Service investigators explain this to me
and this is how I've always understood it
it's not someone calling a claim against you
both parents are like
being investigated
and both parents are on the chopping block
this is an investigation into the children
and the safety of their life and their environments
that's why they go to both
it doesn't matter who the report was called on
that doesn't matter
all that matters is something triggered a call
and now Child Protective Services is looking out for these kids
it's not like both parents are
are under the microscope
whether it was
whether you're the parent that they're claiming something
did something or not
they're still looking at both parents equally as hard
cause they're like well what is going on in these kids lives
it's just an open door into the kids lives
it's not necessarily like rawr
you're the bad guy and they're looking at you some kind of way
so like they all work this job and understand how it works
and understand the people who call in calls
you know what I mean
like no one's oblivious to what's going on
sometimes they just don't have a lot of power to do much
or they do have power and they do take action
but it's truly not as scary as you would think it is
and that's all I was trying to get across